6 grad und traktieren seit
tagesordnungspunkt beschäftigt sich mit
der deutschen u 7 präsidentschaft
deutschland hält dieses jahr den vorsitz
der jährlich rotiert und der soll laut
der bundesregierung unter dem motto
fortschritt für eine gerechte welt
gestellt werden also dem wie die korona
krise finanzpolitik
geschlechtergerechtigkeit bildung
demokratie und auch die klimawende
sollen dort angesprochen werden zum
beispiel sollen die nationalen programme
aufeinander abgestimmt werden so dass
ein land was besonders sich für den
klimaschutz einsetzt nicht
handelshemmnisse fürchten muss aber auch
außenpolitische themen wie russland
ukraine werden der deutschen
präsidentschaft bei der g 7 werden sie
beschäftigen alexander radwan spricht
als erstes für die unionsfraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
deutschland hat dieses jahr turnusgemäß
die präsidentschaft der g 7 übernommen
der westliche westlichen wichtigen
industrienationen demokratischen
nationen
und führt jetzt die präsidentschaft bei
diesen staaten in einer sehr sehr
turbulenten zeit hier ist wichtig
führung und orientierung zu geben und
einen gemeinsamen werte gebunden weg zu
finden und neben dem wertgebundene im
bereich der uns wichtig ist ist auch das
gemeinsam für uns wichtig und die ersten
erfahrungen
in dieser legislaturperiode
lassen eher das gegenteil befürchten mit
blick auf die ukraine nehmen die
internationalen irritationen er zu über
deutschland als ab beim thema klima ist
es auch so dass man zwar generell das
klimaziel verfolgt und hier einen
konsensualen weg in europa gehen möchte
wenn aber dann eine taxonomie
entsprechend diskutiert wird ist der
aufschrei groß und ich finde das umso
bemerkenswerter dass ausgerechnet bei
der taxonomie ist die grünen waren die
diesen diesen entscheidungsprozess sehr
sehr gut fanden die nicht mal als
demokratisch sehr fragwürdig gehalten
hat nach dem motto entsprechende
mehrheiten gegen einen vorschlag zu
bekommen ist jetzt umso schwieriger aber
ich denke mir das sollten wir separat
bei diesem thema diskutieren aber es ist
wichtig dabei den energiemix in anderen
mitgliedstaaten entsprechend zu
respektieren
die thema das thema co2 und klima ist
auch in der g7 ein wichtiges thema und
darum wünsche ich der bundesregierung
viel erfolg eine co2 bepreisung
international
durchzubringen und insbesondere dann
auch einen entsprechenden ausgleich
mechanismus zu verankern zu diskutieren
für die wto wenn es entsprechende import
in die europäischen union gibt die dann
eben nicht diesen entsprechenden co2
kosten unterliegen meine damen und
herren darum sind diese ziele und ich
habe mir das dokument der deutschen
präsident auf angeschaut sehr wichtig
klima umwelt soziales arbeit standard
das sind alles gleichstellung alles sehr
wichtige ziele aber daneben sollte man
die schritte gehen die möglich sind
das sind regionale zusammenschlüsse wir
haben ja die situation dass dieses jahr
das abkommen
mit japan südkorea den asian staaten
china australien und den und neuseeland
also staaten mit unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen strukturen die aber
30 prozent der wirtschaft und 30 prozent
der bevölkerung repräsentieren dass
diese ab diesem jahr arbeitet
das trans pazifische abkommen ist in
verhandlung und auch großbritannien und
die usa verhandeln mit kindern meine
damen und herren das heißt andere nehmen
regionale zusammenschlüsse ernst und
versuchen darüber den welthandel
entsprechend zu beeinflussen und
standards zu setzen und an der spitze
ist es china meine damen und herren
darum ist es dringend notwendig dass
deutschland das europa die möglichkeiten
nutzt die es hat und da spreche ich das
mercure abkommen mit südamerika
lateinamerika und insbesondere das
zweite abkommen mit dem g7 staat kanada
dass wir das endlich voranbringen um
eine appell geht hier insbesondere an
eine fraktion hier ihren widerstand
aufzugeben und diesen entsprechenden
schritt voranzugehen wir haben
wir haben es bei tief erlebt die chance
war da die tür ging zu und dann hatten
wir einen präsidenten in den usa der
entsprechend dagegen gegen den
internationalen handel gearbeitet habt
meine damen und herren andere schaffen
darüber fakten und wir schauen zu und
als wenn es bestellt gewesen wäre aber
es war natürlich nicht bestellt lassen
sie mich auch dem heutigen handelsblatt
zitieren der kontinent macht sich zum
maß aller dinge und verärgert so
wichtige handelspartner
selbstbezogenheit der eu manche ihre
mitgliedstaaten in dem artikel kommt
insbesondere deutschland so einen
ausdruck wirkt irritierend diesen
artikel diese namensartikel von heute
stammt von den früheren
parteivorsitzenden scharping gabriel ich
kann ihnen nur zustimmen ja man muss die
großen ziele verfolgen aber auch man
muss mit den kleinen schritten beginnen
und darum fordere ich die jetzige
regierung auf und die koalition
ratifizieren sind die handelsabkommen
als schritte der machbarkeit die jetzt
auf dem tisch liegen ich wünsche ihnen
sehr viel erfolg bei g7 der
gemeinsamkeit der geschlossenheit in
dieser internationalen runde aber dazu
bedarf es natürlich auch erst einmal der
geschlossenheit in der bundesregierung
in der koalition und daran hapert ist
leider gottes schöpfung sei erstmal da
entsprechend an besten dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
war das mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss wie auch der nächste redner
andreas larem für die
spd-fraktion steht hier schon bereit die
frage was korrekt
nächster redner ist der kollege andreas
lagern spd-fraktion zu seiner ersten
parade
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren seit dem ersten januar
2022 hat deutschland den vorsitz der g 7
die bundesregierung hat hierzu in der
letzten woche ein ausführliches programm
vorgestellt die schwerpunkte sind klima
gesundheit und die stärkung der
demokratie
die kombi 19 pandemie ist allgegenwärtig
70 prozent der weltbevölkerung soll nach
dem willen der
weltgesundheitsorganisation bis 20 22
geimpft sein die bundesregierung
unterstützt die vero bei der erreichung
dieses ziels
dafür soll die globale impfkampagne
beschleunigt werden und die lokale in
produktion in den entwicklungsländern
weiter unterstützt werden die
bundesregierung will weiterhin die
präsidentschaft nutzen um die leitende
und koordinierende rolle der vera
auszubauen
insgesamt nimmt die bundesregierung die
agenda 2030 mit ihre
nachhaltigkeitsziele zum zentralen
referenzrahmen für die g7
präsidentschaft
die pandemie hatte schweren rückschlägen
bei der erreichung der
nachhaltigkeitsziele geführt die g7
sehen wir in besonderer verantwortung
die nachhaltigkeitsziele ambitioniert
umzusetzen lokal national und global
hier sei insbesondere das ziel der
gleichstellung der geschlechter genannt
im rahmen der g7 präsidentschaft wollen
wir die gleichstellung auch global
voranbringen besonders wichtig ist uns
in diesen unruhigen zeiten dass die
bundesregierung die rolle der g7 als
brückenbauer und vermittler für frieden
und sicherheit stärken will fest
eingebettet in die multilaterale
regelbasierte ordnung insbesondere die
vereinten nationen will sie mit den g7
lösungswege für krisenlagen entwickeln
und deren umsetzung arbeiten dabei
sollen krisenprävention und abrüstung im
mittelpunkt stehen
wir wollen demokratische institutionen
und menschenrechte schützen und stärken
auch die wahrnehmung des internationalen
rechts werden wir mit nachdruck
verteidigen zur besseren prävention
wollen wir die vorausschauende
humanitäre hilfe stärken um drohende und
klima induzierte humanitäre krisen
bereits im vorfeld zu verhindern und
dabei ist es besonders wichtig die
freiheit und integrität von informations
sicherzustellen freie und unabhängige
medien und gesicherte und verlässliche
informationen
spielen für starke demokratien eine
zentrale rolle
die demokratische
meinungsbildungsprozesse müssen
verfälschungen und verzerrung vor
fälschungen und vor verzerrungen
geschützt werden hassreden bekämpft
meinungsfreiheit sichergestellt und die
sicherheit von journalistinnen und
journalisten gewährleistet werden
anknüpfend an bestehende prozesse wollen
wir in der g7
geeignete präventive ansätze zur
verbesserung der informations integrität
entwickeln und unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger noch besser dabei unterstützen
des informationen und verschwörungs
ideologien zu erkennen und aktiv
entgegenzutreten können
zusätzlich wollen wir die
wissenschaftskommunikation stärken meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren die
internationale zusammenarbeit ist
extremst wichtig wenn wir uns einig sind
können wir viel erreichen und wir haben
viel vor und wir werden es anpacken
vielen dank
die verschiedenen aspekte wie
deutschland die g7 präsidentschaft
nutzen wird in diesem jahr 2022 das ist
das thema in dieser debatte markus frohn
meyer spricht als nächstes er ist
mitglied der fdp-fraktion und dort
entwicklungspolitischer sprecher
[Applaus]
ident meine damen und herren wir haben
diese woche viel gelernt cdu und csu
schaffen es ohne hilfe der afd nicht
einmal einen eigenen konservativen
kandidaten für den bundespräsidenten
aufzustellen
und heute lernen wir cdu und csu können
auch keine parlaments anträge schreiben
in dem antrag der union zur außenpolitik
den wir heute besprechen das schreiben
sie tatsächlich die neue bundesregierung
solle libyen und die sahel zone
stabilisieren den krieg im jemen beenden
die humanitäre krise in afghanistan
lindern den terrorismus im irak und
syrien bekämpfen warum fordern sie nicht
gleich den weltfrieden wer war denn die
letzten 16 jahre an der regierung waren
16 jahre der kanzlerschaft angela
merkels nicht genug um diese forderungen
in die realität umzusetzen oder warum
warum legen sie uns heute ein machwerk
vor mit 20 punkten zusammen geschustert
was sie da machen das muss man wirklich
sagen ist billig und ist es bezeichnen
dass keiner der vorredner bisher darauf
eingegangen ist sie fordern vom links
gelben bündnis die abarbeitung eines
außenpolitischen programms dass sie
selber nicht abgearbeitet haben als sie
in der regierung wach bahn was sie hier
machen dass ist keine seriöse
oppositionspolitik das ist kaspertheater
viele ihre forderungen die sind so
haarsträubend dass ich fast dankbar bin
das muss ich an der stelle wirklich
betonen dass sie in 16 jahren angela
merkel überhaupt gar nicht zur umsetzung
gekommen sind so wollen sie die g7 um
einen sogenannten
internationalen klima club erweitern
greta turmberg dachte dann zukünftig
platz nehmen zwischen joe biden und
emanuel makro und den g 7 gipfel
eröffnen ist dass die staatstragende
union unter friedrich merz von der alle
sprechen oder auch ein schöner
treppenwitz deutschland soll endlich die
vorgaben der nato umsetzen und zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes in
die bundeswehr stecken ja wer waren denn
die letzten fünf verteidigungsminister
liebe kollegen kramp karrenbauer cdu von
der leyen cdu de maizière cdu guttenberg
csu und jung cdu 16 jahre haben sie das
militär kaputt gespart und jetzt
besitzen sie die unverfrorenheit sich
hier als retter der bundeswehr auf zu
spielen das ist an heuchelei nicht zu
überbieten
schließlich möchten sie
entwicklungsländern alle schulden
erlassen bezahlen darf das dann der
deutsche steuerzahler unterzeichnet
haben den antrag
brinkhaus dobrindt und die fraktion
ehrlicher wäre gewesen pleiten pech und
schulden vielen dank
dank der kollege von meyer
[Applaus]
nicht zu reden ist der kollege womit
nouripour fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die bundesregierung übernimmt nun die
präsidentschaft der g 7 in zeiten sehr
großer globale aufgaben und
dementsprechend sie noch die
schwerpunkte die für die agenda gesetzt
worden sind dieser bundesregierung sehr
ambitioniert und das ist auch gut so es
gibt einen sehr klaren schwerpunkt auch
gut abgestimmt in allen häusern und auch
vom auswärtigen amt nach vorne gestellt
nämlich klimaschutz das ist eine aufgabe
die gewaltig und großes und auch in
deutschland haben wir seit vieles zu tun
die haben es an der
bilanzpressekonferenz des klima minister
sohn des vize-kanzlers robert habe
letzte woche gesehen es ist sehr sehr
viel nachzuholen was in den letzten
jahren liegen gelassen worden ist bei
aller rhetorik der menschheitsaufgabe
und es ist eine menschheitsaufgabe und
jetzt muss man auch dementsprechend
agieren wenn man sich aber
wenn man sich aber die signatur staaten
von paris anschaut und deren klimaziele
und sie zusammen addiert alle diese
staaten mögen ihre nationalen klimaziele
einhalten dann langt mir bei 2,4 grad
erwärmung und das ist schlicht nicht
genug um das zeigt dass wir da weit mehr
tun müssen und dass es in der g 7 frage
genau die richtige und deshalb stelle
ich das hier auch kann den anfang wir
brauchen eine weltweite allianz
natürlich auch ausgehend von den g 7 und
ja es muss über know how transfer
diskutiert werden wenn es um technologie
geht für den klimaschutz und ja es
müssen auch vereinbarungen geben über
wege der co2 verpressung und ja es geht
natürlich auch um fortschreiten und
reformbemühungen es ist vorhin auch vom
kollegen hofreiter ich finde völlig zu
recht das thema grenze
grenz ausgleichsmechanismus bei co2
innerhalb von green die benannt worden
auch da wir das innerhalb von g7 sehr
viele gespräche geben müssen es ist auch
gut so wir werden aber
auch mehr machen müssen in dem bereich
und wir werden all diese maßnahmen auch
global natürlich unterfüttern müssen und
nicht auseinander gehen lassen dürfen
bei menschenrechten und bei den sozialen
ausgleich und natürlich ist es absolut
zentral dass wir weiterhin setzen auf
lokale zivilgesellschaften die
unermesslich wichtiges leisten gerade
auch im thema klimaschutz im übrigen der
konflikt zurzeit mit der ukraine zeigt
wie richtig es ist was robert habeck vor
wenigen wochen von diesem pult ausgesagt
hat entscheidend ist dass wir endlich
herunterkommen von unserem hunger nach
fossilen das ist nicht nur ein gebot von
klimaschutz das ist nicht nur ein
ökonomisches gebot das ist auch ein
gebot der friedenspolitik und dort
werden wir sehr viel mehr leistung
die pandemie ist ein weiterer
schwerpunkt dieser präsidentschaft auch
das ist gut und richtig so und eine
pandemie ist weltweit und vom tag eins
an sagen alle die sich damit auskennen
die pandemie ist erst dann beendet wenn
sie weltweit beendet ist es ist bekannt
dass je länger die pandemie dauert
länger hilfe auch für die schwächeren
aus bleibt desto mehr dass die
möglichkeit gibt von neuen variationen
von neuen mutanten und deshalb ist es
notwendig einfach auch dort ins team zu
kommen es ist gut dass kovacs im letzten
jahr 800 millionen impfdosen verteilt
hat auch gerade für die schwächeren es
ist gut dass die g7 jetzt für dieses
jahr 900 millionen impfdosen auch in
aussicht gestellt haben aber die müssen
ja auch vererbt werden das muss ja auch
kühlketten gehen und das ist ja auch
notwendig dass die haltbarkeitsdaten
auch den end passenden kapazitäten die
sehr minimal sind teilweise vor ort auch
passend tatsächlich dazu passen und
deshalb ist es absolut notwendig auch
auf kapazitäten aufbauen schwachen
staaten zu setzen das ist ein
schwerpunkt dieser präsidentschaft und
das ist auch gut so übrigens auch
deswegen weil wir ja auch wissen beim
nächsten pandemien die es geben kann und
die nicht unwahrscheinlich sind dass es
bei globale gesundheit natürlich auch um
infrastruktur im gesundheitssystem auf
der ganzen welt ankommt dass das nicht
nur ein gebot der solidarität auch ein
angebot des selbstschutzes
und
und der dritte schwerpunkt den ich hier
noch einmal herausstellen will ist die
stärkung des wie der widerstandskraft
unserer demokratien unserer demokratie
ist ein unter einem massiven stress test
wir haben es zu tun mit
extremisten wir haben es zu tun mit
gewaltbereiten und wir haben es zu tun
mit einer massiven schleuder von
falschen informationen
und eine unterminierung von vertrauen
damit ist es umso klarer dass wir alle
gemeinschaftlich wenn wir demokratien
demokraten sind eintreten müssen für
gute und für unabhängige journalistische
arbeit und diesen falschen auch
entgegenzutreten und werde ich jetzt mir
anschaue wie russia today deutsch
beispielsweise dieser tage agiert und
welche zwischenspiele es geht
beispielsweise zwischen der afg und
russia today dann ist das eindeutig die
arbeit nicht für deutschland sondern
gegen die demokratie und machen sich
dort auch noch zum weg wir werden alle
gemeinsam dem entgegentreten das ist das
gebot der demokratie
auch im rahmen der gegend
jugendchor war das am freitag und
samstag findet der digitale parteitag
der grünen stadt und omid nouripour und
ricarda lang werden dort antreten um als
duo den parteivorsitz übernehmen zu
übernehmen natürlich überträgt phoenix
auf diesen digitalen parteitag jetzt
geht es hier aber in der debatte weiter
gregor gysi für die linksfraktionen der
außenpolitische sprecher herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
deutschland die g7 präsidentschaft
nutzen will muss es nicht um führung
gehen sondern um handlungsfähigkeit und
handlungswillen was könnte g7 tun
endlich entsprechend auch einen
vorschlag des amerikanischen präsidenten
die patente für impfstoffe gegen das
gros navis wieso wir es gerade für die
sogenannte dritte welt frei gibt es wird
höchste zeit aber der größte bremser
diesbezüglich ist die bundesregierung
nur damit die erfinder ihr dickes geld
bekommen wir brauchen eine deutliche
einschränkung von rüstungsexporten seit
1998 hat deutschland kriegsgerät für 120
milliarden euro exportiert bei den
anderen sechs ländern ist es zum teil
noch schlimmer wer so waffen exportiert
exportiert auch krieg das muss aufhören
dann brauchen wir deutlich mehr mittel
für die entwicklungszusammenarbeit ich
meine die uno hat beschlossen 0,7
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
tulloch g7 staaten sind davon noch
entfernt und die rechnerischen tricks
diesbezüglich müssen auch aufhören dann
müssen wir die roten wie ein
freihandelsabkommen überwinden ich muss
das mal vorstellen wir können in ein
armes armes afrikanisches land zu
liefern und die dürfen zu uns auch
zollfreie liefern also einen größeren
wahnsinns ungleichheit kann man sich
kaum vorstellen
und dann müssen verschlossenen
klimaziele gerade erst mal die g7
erreichen bevor sie immer nur andere
länder am an was braucht gesehen eine
erneuerung diese anzustoßen wäre eine
aufgabe für den bundeskanzler
existenzielle fragen sind längst
menschheitsprobleme über den nicht mehr
sieben staaten entscheiden können die
sieben staaten gehören noch dazu zu den
hauptverursachern der probleme
klimasünder soziale ungleichheit kriege
ressourcenknappheit die multipolare welt
in der wir leben braucht zumindest eine
einbindung auf chinas russlands indiens
und brasiliens
venture in china in der korona pandemie
eine ähnliche infektions verbreitung für
die usa zu belassen hätte dann sähe es
schlimm aus unserer welt fazit die g7
staaten müssen endlich von ihrem sockel
runter und den weg der internationalen
zusammenarbeit des interessenausgleichs
und des friedens beschreiten
hier hat man noch ein leises
tschuldigung sohn gregor gysi gehört
weil er nicht sofort an seiner maske
gedacht hat und die abgeordneten dürfen
die maske zwar während der rede absetzen
aber dann auf dem weg zum platz müssen
sie sie gleich wieder aufsetzen
und spricht jetzt für die fdp fraktion
ist lässt
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und gelegen ich bitte
um ein wort vorweg was wahrscheinlich
meine redezeit ein bisschen sprengen
wird aber an einem tag wie heute meine
erste rede zu halten dass es unglaublich
emotional für mich und deswegen bitte
ich um verständnis
jetzt zum einen punkt denn eines wird in
diesen tagen deutlich
die aufrechte haltung des dialogs
scheint wichtiger denn je doch dazu
braucht es foren es braucht neue trage
räume und menschen die bereit sind
verantwortung zu übernehmen das normandy
format zur vermittlung im konflikt die
nato die g7 die g20 und die osze sie
alle sind multilaterale prämien die für
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
zur aufrechterhaltung des dialogs
unerlässlich sind für deutschland bieten
diese dialogforen die chance sich mit
unseren internationalen partnern für
eine multilaterale demokratische und
werte basierte ordnung und für eine
offene gesellschaft einzusetzen
dem format der g7 kommt dabei eine
besondere rolle zu und dies nicht nur
deshalb weil die bundesrepublik
deutschland gegenwärtig den vorsitz
innehat die globalen herausforderungen
vor denen die internationale
staatengemeinschaft steht sind immens
wir müssen auf internationaler ebene mit
den folgen des klimawandels umgehen wir
sehen uns konfrontiert mit den
gesundheitlichen wirtschaftlichen
politischen und sozialen folgen der coop
19 pandemie wir müssen wir uns mit den
anhaltenden territorial konflikten an
den rändern der europäischen union und
weit darüber hinaus auseinandersetzen
wir brauchen pragmatische liberale
antworten und strategien im umgang mit
prozessen der zunehmenden
automatisierung
den g7 die als wertegemeinschaft
liberaler demokratien zu den führenden
industrienationen zählen kommt dabei in
anbetracht des globalen ausmaß ist
dieser konflikt und herausforderung eine
besondere vorreiterrolle zu sie verfügen
nicht nur über die wirtschaftlichen
ressourcen und über das know how und
lösungsstrategien zu entwickeln sondern
sind auch auf multilaterale
multilateraler ebene eng vernetzt davor
sitzen der g 7 bietet für die
bundesrepublik eine wichtige chance
gemeinsam mit unseren partnern auf
internationaler ebene verantwortung zu
übernehmen und unseren beitrag zur
bewältigung der großen globalen
herausforderungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zu leisten
das programm der deutschen gesellschaft
bekennt sich ausdrücklich zu unserer
vorreiterrolle innerhalb einer werte
basierten multicar 3 in ordnung die
ampel regierung tritt für die schaffung
einer starken allianz für fortschritt
beim klimaschutz ein sie forciert in
ihrem programm den immanenten
zusammenhang zwischen einer ökologischen
und sozial gerechten transformation und
wirtschaftlichem wachstum der
nachhaltigkeit und wohlstand schließen
sich nicht gegenseitig aus im gegenteil
die deutsche g7 präsidentschaft setzt
auf wachstumsorientierte
wirtschaftspolitik im bewusstsein um
unsere ökologische verantwortung
sie setzt auf den ausbau von
partnerschaften zu klima energie
entwicklung frieden und sicherheit und
die stärkung der demokratie und der
zivilgesellschaft weltweit das interesse
an unterschiedlichen kultur kulturellen
hintergründen kann dabei brücken bauen
und demokratie verständnis fördern dabei
schöpft unserer ampel regierung endlich
das potenzial aus dass investitionen in
infrastruktur wie zb die sogenannte work
better world initiative ich habe es
recht ausgeprägt damit leisten wir zur
nachhaltigen transition reaktionsweg
prozent unser meister
und die bundesregierung er weist auf die
auszeichnung zur bedeutung die wehrhafte
liberaler demokratien nicht nur für den
schutz von menschen und bürgerrechten
haben sondern auch für den
wirtschaftlichen wohlstand
denn eine demokratische werteordnung
wirtschaftlicher wohlstand und
ökologische nachhaltigkeit müssen
zusammengedacht werden die g7 unter
deutschem vorsitz sind geeint ich
demokratische wertvorstellungen bekennt
sich wie es im programm deklaratorisch
heißt sie ihrer verantwortung für das
globale gemeinwohl
doch das gelingt uns nicht alleine
dialog braucht taten auf augenhöhe die
g7 bieten ein geeignetes forum und
gleichberechtigte partnerschaften zu
stärken aber auch um darüber hinaus neue
partnerschaften zu schmieden und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
ihr antrag zur nutzung dieses deutschen
g7 präsidentschaft in allen ehren aber
ein blick in das programm zeigt dass
sich die bundesrepublik in ihrer
führungsverantwortung mit schwierigen
zeiten durchaus bewusst ist mit vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
und
monaten gab es 82
klaus in ihrem ersten rede nina scheer
ist die nächste rednerin
sprecherin für klimaschutz und energie
von der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
präsidentin
erstmal gucken das geschäft richtig
ausgedrückt so die klimakrise könnte die
g7 staaten wenn nicht mehr gehandelt
wird im jahr 2050 8,5 prozent ihrer
wirtschaftsleistung kosten das macht 4,8
billionen dollar aus das ist eine
abstrakte zahl aber allein diese
ökonomische betrachtung zeigt dass mit
welche mit welchen dimensionen wird zu
rechnen haben und mit ihnen einhergeht
mit dieser betrachtung einhergeht der
verlust von lebensgrundlagen und
millionenfache flucht und auch
millionenfaches menschliches leid
insofern ist es richtig dass auch die
klimaschutzpolitik einen weiteren und
einen zentralen schwerpunkt in der g7
präsidentschaft stellt und bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hat auch insofern so richtig
erweise erklärt dass dies so sein soll
und ich erhoffe mir auch dass auf diesem
signal mit dieser schwerpunktsetzung in
mit diesen staaten kreis auch eine
vorreiterfunktion verbunden werden wird
damit eben
klimafreundliches wirtschaften zum
standard zum weltweiten standard mit
ausstrahlungswirkung wird
geht auch einher mit klimaschutzpolitik
das ist nicht nur eine eine mahnende
politik sondern es ist eine politik die
chancen weil mit ihr einhergeht arbeit
mit zukunft und geht eben auch eine
zukunft für viele kategorien mit denen
wir politisch zu tun haben dem
energiesektor der für einen bedeutenden
teil
die mission steht kommt aber eine
entscheidende schlüsselrolle zu und auch
auf nationaler ebene bedeutet das
natürlich einen drastischen und
beschleunigten umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien also einen trust beschleunigten
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien zu
realisieren und damit einher muss gehen
die beseitigung von ausbau hemmnissen
und auch die beseitigung von mängeln
beschränkungen die auch bedeuten müssen
dass wir einen anreiz bekommen möglichst
die ziele die wir uns gesetzt haben noch
zu überrunden denn anders ist es in der
tat nicht zu schaffen die weltweiten
handlungsbedarfe hinzubekommen
der ausbau erneuerbarer energien liegt
dabei im überragenden öffentlichen
interesse das hat die koalition
festgeschrieben und wir sind auch schon
mitten im geschehen wenn wir sehen dass
bundesminister habe ich da jetzt auch
schon eine erste paket in vorbereitung
hat und auch weitergehende maßnahmen
die abhängigkeit von fossilen energien
kann wenn wir sie nicht umgehend zu
beenden wissen zu ungeahnten armut
fallen werden und auch zum kollabieren
von volkswirtschaften und sie führen
auch zu geopolitischen konflikten wie
bereits an den irak kriegen zu erkennen
gewesen war und auch aktuellen bezug auf
den grundkonflikt zwischen der ukraine
und russland muss uns bewusst sein dass
in dieser konflikt lage trotz
verschiedenster tier wirkende interesses
gegensätzen auf allen seiten auch eine
verflechtung mit abhängigkeiten von
fossilen ressourcen besteht wenn wir den
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien nicht
zügig schaffen werden solche konflikte
immer wahrscheinlicher
atomenergie ist dabei keine lösung
sie ist die teuerste energie sie ist
eine hochrisikotechnologie wir haben
ungelöste endlagerfrage und insofern ist
es auch völlig richtig dass die
bundesregierung die stellungnahme
abgegeben hat dass atomenergie nicht
nachhaltig ist und ich möchte auch noch
einmal klose tun das auch frankreich ein
finanzierungslevel entworfen hat und in
kraft gesetzt hat
mit atomenergie nicht nachhaltig ist
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
so war die rede von nina scheer damit
kommen wir zur vorletzten rednerin in
dieser debatte das ist katja leikert für
die unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es sind außen und sicherheitspolitisch
herausfordernde ernst zu zeiten und ja
die man kollegin nouripour die
demokratien befinden sich aktuell in
einem stresstest und angesichts der
massiven kulisse die russland an der
grenze zur ukraine aufgebaut hat vergeht
kein tag an dem wir hier in berlin ich
inständig von unseren partnern
aufgefordert werden unsere verpflichtung
als bündnispartner klar und eindeutig
nachzukommen wir werden aufgefordert
unsere werte von demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit und
territoriale unversehrtheit gegen
autokratische ansprüche zu verteidigen
und die signale die die ampel aussendet
sind leider alles andere als klar wir
von seiten der cdu csu sind da
unmissverständlich was wir brauchen ist
viel verständnis und unterstützung für
die ukraine und weniger verständnis für
russland und was wir brauchen ist eine
echte verteidigung unserer lebensweise
und eine klare absage an putins
provokation
und ja unsere passt liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen können das von uns
verlangen diese klarheit und eine feste
zusage denn dafür sind hier partner da
und was wir brauchen ist diese
verlässlichkeit natürlich wenn es zum
äußersten kommt wenn es zu einer
militärischen bedrohung kommt aber wir
brauchen diese verlässlichkeit eben auch
grundsätzlich wir brauchen sie in der
nato wir brauchen sie in der
europäischen union wir brauchen sie auf
ebene der g-7-staaten die größten
demokratischen industrienationen müssen
sich auf deutschland verlassen können
und deshalb bringen wir heute einen
antrag zur deutschen g7 präsidentschaft
ein mit der klagen und dringenden
aufforderung an die bundesregierung und
so lautet auch unser titel in
schwierigen zeiten führung zu zeigen und
genau das wünschen wir uns von ihnen die
gesinnung präsidentschaft ist wichtig
und sie vielleicht die wichtigste in den
letzten jahren und putin wird sich die
gelegenheit nicht nehmen lassen er tut
es ja bereits jetzt nicht uns die agenda
zu bestimmen weil er weiß liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen insbesondere
von der spd dass sie damit
schwierigkeiten im umgang haben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
fraktionen aber wenn putin schon die
tagesordnung bestimmen wird dann müssen
wir eben etwas dagegen stellen und als
teil der demokratischen gemeinschaft
stehen wir eben im system konkurrenz
nicht nur zu russland sondern auch zu
china und wir fordern sie dringend mit
diesem auftrag antrag auf dass sie klar
machen dass die g7 als wertegemeinschaft
sehr selbstbewusst antritt um weltweit
regeln und standards zu setzen wir
brauchen dringend regeln für den cyber
raum für keitany für block chains für
international die internationale
finanzwelt und wir stehen für einen
fairen und freien handel und leben
protektionismus ab
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
insbesondere im links grünen spektrum
der ampel zu diesen regeln gehört auch
mehr person und dazu gehört auch
das sind musterbeispiele für
regelsetzung die die die widerständig
verteufeln und ich hoffe dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp da
noch überzeugungsarbeit leisten können
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abschließend damit diese präsidentschaft
gelingen kann reicht es nicht sie nur
mit wolkigen überschriften zu füllen von
der präsidentschaft wird zurecht
authentizität und eine vorbildrolle
verlangt nehmen sie bitte diese
führungsrolle im rahmen der g7
präsidentschaft an kämpfen wir gemeinsam
für unsere werte herzlichen dank
der bundestag diskutiert anlässlich
eines antrags der unionsfraktion die
abgeordneten werden gleich noch darüber
abstimmen ob
diese vorlage direkt abgestimmt wird
oder erst an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen wird vorher hören
wir aber noch den stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden des ausschusses für
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
das ist markus tönt aus der spd fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
präsidentin
deutschland übernimmt die g7
präsidentschaft in einer
herausfordernden
herausfordernden zeit und ich möchte den
blick mehr jetzt im moment meiner rede
auf die handels politischen aspekte der
g7 präsidentschaft richten
in den vergangenen jahren ist deutlich
geworden dass
die verketten gerade in der pandemie
schwer erschüttert wurden die folgen
sind das ohne ihn lief
fast unmöglich wurde jobs in time
produktion kam zum stillstand und das
zeigt auch noch mal deutlich dass wir
hier nachdenken müssen dass wir neu
denken müssen und es wurde vor augen
geführt schmerzlich wie verletzlich auch
unsere europäische wirtschaft ist aber
nicht nur die pandemie stellt uns vor
große herausforderungen meine damen und
herren auch die krise der wto und die
daraus folgende krise des regelbasierten
handels in der welt hat eine enorme
bedeutung
die bekämpfung des klimawandels werden
hier nicht schaffen wenn wir nicht auch
regeln im handel lieferketten im blick
haben und das ganze auch sehr ordentlich
mit den partnerinnen und partnern im g7
besprechen
und deswegen ist es wichtig und richtig
dass die deutsche g7 präsidentschaft
sich dieser themen annimmt und ich
möchte
drei punkte hervorheben die aus meiner
sicht noch einmal begonnen besondere
bedeutung haben das eine ist wir
brauchen eine reform der wto sie ist
seit jahren blockiert finanziell
strukturell wir brauchen wieder eine
herstellung des streitbeilegung
mechanismus eine stärkere
berücksichtigung von
nachhaltigkeitsaspekten in der wto und
wir brauchen neue impulse für ein
regelbasiertes handeln für einen
regelbasierten handeln
und zweitens
meine damen und herren wir brauchen
residente die verkennen dabei stehen
fragen im raum was kann man tun um einen
zusammenbruch der lieferketten zukünftig
zu verhindern wie muss handel gestaltete
zahlen damit der resilient und
ökologisch ist und nachhaltig das
engined entscheidende fragen und
drittens liebe kollegen und pflegen wir
brauchen einheitliche
wettbewerbsbedingungen
weltweit
es bedarf eines einheitlichen web
einheitliche wettbewerbsbedingungen
in einem wto regelwerk und deshalb bin
ich der bundesregierung ausdrücklich
dankbar
dass sie gerade in ihrem programm
handels politisch sich so viel vornimmt
das ist deutlich mehr als in ihrem
antrag steht für dr leikert das müssen
sie leider mal sagen und ich
habe große hoffnung auf den gipfel im
juni aber sie haben in ihrem antrag ja
auch ich will das jetzt auch nicht ins
nicht ins lächerliche ziehen aber schon
von dem vakuum
geschrieben dass sie frau dr merkel
hinterlässt ich glaube sie hatten dabei
wohl mehr im blick das vakuum dass frau
dr merkel in der cdu und in ihrer
fraktion hinterlässt als stadt in diesem
b 7 frage also wie steht vor großen
herausforderungen und ich bin
ausdrücklich dankbar dass die
bundesregierung diese so konsequent
anfassen vielen dank
damit sie sich jetzt die aussprache